holy pumpkin pie Happy Thanksgiving you
guys you recently put us over 1 million
subscribers now that's something to be
thankful for to say thank you we decided
to read your comments and questions
it's the Thanksgiving comment and
question episode so a lot of you had
questions for the voice of honest
trailers John Bailey
guess what we delivered how you doing
John hi Hal thanks for interrupting my
my Thanksgiving with my family oh it's
our pleasure we have a couple questions
for you from some of your fans Simpsons
Man 1 20 he asks how come the voice in
honest trailers sounds so seducing well
it's the opposite opinion of my wife
maybe just because I say boobs so much I
don't know for all the movie trailer
voice fetishes the pervs out there like
Hollywood Superman give us a little hot
talk I'm going to put my sex parts in
contact with your sex parts fight a
question my own for you John I heard
through the grapevine that you actually
got recognized that's true I went to
Best Buy wearing my honest trailer shirt
and the guys like honest trailers where
have I heard that before and I said
probably you've heard me say be sure to
subscribe and he freaked out and when
dragged me to all his co-workers to let
me know let them know that I was the
voice of honest trailers
that's so cool did you get like special
discounts and stuff because of that no
he couldn't even help me find what I was
looking for
now John I'm sure what you actually mean
is that the Best Buy employee helped you
find everything you needed and gave you
great service we love Best Buy a
frequent sponsor of our show check out
their Black Friday sale John it's been
great having you and on your way out
would you mind honoring us by giving my
sign-off I can try
sure why not thanks for watching guys be
sure to subscribe hit me up on Twitter
I'm Hal Rudnick bye bye Thank You John
Bailey
Happy Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving
gobble gobble Maru
Ruiz de Souza asks how did you come up
with the bye-bye wave well that's a
great question actually and it was a
very thought
out process that we poured over in depth
take a look
I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye that's demure
sign off now bye-bye
okay
I like saying bye-bye Stephen W Farrell
asks what's your most awkward moment
with a celebrity
well we interviewed the cast of Last
Vegas and had Morgan Freeman read the
lyrics of the Fox I also had the chance
to talk to the delightful and lovely
Mary Steenburgen which is when I did
this is it okay if I call you an ageless
beauty Wow it's okay with me can I go
back to what I initially said and say
aging ageless beauty beauty okay go back
and say can I go back to what I just
just said okay Ted Danson please don't
hurt me one of my favorite things about
the holiday is spending time with family
and friends that's why we wanted to
bring in one of the best friends of the
show mr. Nick Mundy Nick oh you old
scallywag get in here Thanks happy
Thanksgiving mad love to be here and not
with my friends and family so we got a
lot of questions for you Nick from
a-team 667 I want to know what Nick
Mundy thought about the series finale of
Breaking Bad it was good it was really
good
nothing that got under your skin no it's
really really good I'm not a monster I
like it I want to like everything I
think we gonna wouldn't like it a came
Zim Smith asks if you could get Nick
Mundy screaming at a turkey for
Thanksgiving you would make the rest of
this year and next year the happiest I
have been in a while well sorry about
your life Zim but we want to make it
happy for you this is a frozen turkey
breast Nick have at it this is all I get
to yell at you wanted me to yell at a
turkey get me a turkey to yell at it's
barely a turkey it looks like I am if
you want me to yell at something hey I
got an idea for another episode since
you just do a jerk on episodes how to
fix it turkey okay how's that zim zim I
hope that was everything you dreamed it
would be
that this year is a happier one for you
Nick Mundy thank you for stopping by
well Turkey Hannah I don't have anywhere
to go all right well you don't have to
go home but you can't stay here Nick
Mundy everybody
spending Thanksgiving it Hometown Buffet
Nick how many trips to the ice cream bar
you gonna make okay yeah I mean next we
heard from Rudy Vasquez who said last
Thanksgiving I said your arms were
hairiest Rudy Vasquez says your arms are
hairy as I still stand by my word Turkey
grandma's pecan pie and how's hairiest
arms a new Thanksgiving tradition I
thank you Rudy I'm on the subject of me
being hairiest derp derp Stan asks do
you ever consider shaving Hal Rudnick
and sending about a ton of his hair to
poverty-stricken countries to be used as
blankets
that's about the quality of question I
expect from someone named derp derp Stan
and you know what that's not going to
happen because shaving all this hair and
sending it to other countries would make
those countries too damn sexy derp too
damn sexy got a lot of screen junkies
related questions from you guys let's
take a look
pure Pat 69 asks it seems that you are
boss of SJ that's screen junkies am i
right Spencer you write for screen
junkies you write a lot of the honest
trailers am I the boss here then you're
a director editor of everything what do
you think oh well Andy created
everything so it's really up to him
whatever Hal wants you heard of here on
the boss hey while I have you here why
don't you guys come on in and answer a
couple of the screen junkies question
are we allowed how come on it's
Thanksgiving kissfist movies asks how
many people work with screen junkies
you're looking at them yep yeah we got a
lot of questions about the Shelf do you
guys have a favorite thing or something
you think it's the most valuable thing
on the shelf
my favorite Hal if you want to grab it
behind you I have a Jeff Goldblum from
Independence Day mr. cougar ha ha
much faster onset right yeah a limited
like totally put him on an action heroes
body but kept his Jeff Goldblum head so
one thing when we were building the set
we actually bought a bunch of DVDs from
garage sales because we had to outfit
this huge set and so a lot of people
always ask why ever so many duplicates
this is actually some dude we bought up
eBay had his own four copies of this the
great needs four copies of Master and
Commander you know what
rame at eleven ask Oh asked what's the
most valuable and or unique thing on
those shelves we're going to give you
the least unique thing on the Shelf
we're gonna send you an autographed copy
we're all gonna autograph this copy of
Master sorry and send it to you enjoy
this from screen junkies to you want to
think Spencer a Dan Andy for coming by
and thank you for helping us cross a
million subscribers we're very proud and
thank you awesome now back to work you
guys how you should go to the next clip
okay you got it buddy thank you that was
a nice time thank you for writing in all
of your comments and questions and since
it is Thanksgiving I want to know what
are you thankful for in the world of TV
and movies leave your comment in the
section below and the coolest answer is
going to get a month subscription to
loot crate loot crate is a crate of cool
stuff that comes to your house every
month and let's see what's in this one
it's stuff like oh this awesome
Southpark sound blasting speaker and we
got a cool t-shirt let's see what it is
oh cool ewoking dead that's awesome
so if you wanna know more about loot
crate check it out in the description
below now I'm sure a lot of you are
basking in the glory that is my mustache
it's for Movember which is all about
men's health awareness check out more
about Movember in the description below
as well I want to thank you for watching
happy Thanksgiving out there I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
call your games and been real it's just
non-stop I need to catch hey you know
yeah you don't want to catch fire you
wanna catch thank you